all right i'm seeing security cameras i
need all that footage i need forensics
to run a full sweep of
hey what are all these civilians doing
here who's responsible for securing the
area who screwed this up
hi i'm officer debbie fogle i'm so sorry
my partner's on crowd control
i don't know where he went it's his
first week on the job so he's still
learning the ropes all right listen
fogle we have a councilman in the
hospital and his shooter is still at
large we don't have time for this
incompetence
i want your partner off the case what's
his name it's raymond holt
oh it's dad i mean captain halt
i mean captain dad i mean officer holt i
mean officer dad yep that was it
officer dad i found it detective i
thought i saw our clue on the sidewalk i
apologize for not properly securing the
scene no need to apologize i wasn't even
that mad you said you wanted whoever
messed up off the case
it doesn't matter the point is no one
needs to get in trouble look you don't
have to pity me just because madeline
once demoted me for a year i've been
stripped of my accomplishments and lost
the respect of everyone in my life
including my dog cheddar no yes
now he only poops for gavin oh sir
officer holt
i thought i stationed you not here
right i'm just here in the plaza looking
for um
this a half-eaten box of mcnuggets yep
it's my lunch uh-huh and what type of
food is a mcnugget some type of
uh paella you had to know that was a bad
guess
well the point is i needed my paella and
i noticed the sky bridge so
i thought i might be of some help but
i'll just go back and stand next to a
piece of police tape and do
nothing wait stop how'd you like to
stick around and assist on the case you
sure jake i mean there's only room for
one manhunter the ball's right i don't
want to overstep you're not overstepping
i mean he interrupted the song but
whatever great i'll just leave my pie uh
on the ground saving for later we all
know that's not your lunch
clear in the back copy all clear on the
main hall clear
clear the service road a quarter mile
away is also clear
hold on there's a pigeon approaching
hold the mission
[Music]
true great work with that pitch officer
detective switched to channel five
anyone else getting a sense hopes upset
about the new captain coming tomorrow
look there's no point in rebranding
yourself for the new captain or should i
say
crafton because they're not going to be
here for very long anyways remember
pearl just stopping i don't want to hear
you bad-mouthing my replacement around
the office
do it surreptitiously watch this i hear
the new captain's a pill popper
they're on their way up everyone hide
your pills what a gigantic turd
agreed an unformed pile i don't know she
seemed kind of awesome to me
the thing is she can't be awesome cause
she's here to replace holt but she said
as soon as his year in uniform is
finished she's moving on
that's a pretty generous interpretation
of what she said amy
as soon as this urine uniform is
finished i'll be moving on okay fine
it's exactly what she said but she seems
like a liar someone told me she's a pill
popper pop-pop
[Music]
i'm off to walk my beat again much like
sisyphus condemned to push the same
boulder up the same hill
day in and day out you know according to
french philosopher albert camus sisyphus
achieved happiness in that absurd
repetition
any french philosophy post russo is
essentially a magazine
you rube before we wrap up this briefing
i wanted to give a few shout outs
diaz great job on that b and e you are a
good cop with a great attitude
i don't like this santiago when i think
of your compstat reports
one word comes to mind wow and that wow
is an acronym for
wow oh wow what is happening he's
buttering us up before giving us some
devastatingly bad news
my god jake and charles are dead jake
and charles are not dead
it's worse than that we have to do our
annual hr seminar on workplace conflict
tomorrow
what already i know i got a bean to boil
too
santiago always tries to finish my
sentences and frequently gets it wrong
i do not and i am not wrong you do it
all
the time no i was going to say all the
day long see
frequently wrong who's ready to compete
count me in i could really use this day
off to spend some time with my husband
please we all have loved ones you're not
getting any sympathy just cause you're
gay rosa i don't think he was no i was
she saw right through me nevertheless
i will destroy you all copy that i love
your intensity so any idea who did it
no but whoever it was had an intimate
knowledge of our security systems
it was obviously an inside job i bet it
was brian
why'd he say that because he once said
he has a hot tub
you know how that crowd is i don't know
brian hit a hot tub that does sound bad
yeah this is gonna take forever i
actually took a speed reading course i
tested at 800 wpm
that's pathetic i tested it at 802.
that's pretty close to hold score no no
802's incredible she poned me
i read the entire urban dictionary so i
could converse with the other uniformed
officers
finished it in 47 minutes i've never
been so attracted to a gay man before
and i dated several in college so we
have a read-off santiago
we don't have finger guards so we do it
raw okay i normally don't
encourage such childish competitions but
this might help things go faster my only
question is
are you sure your old-ass eyes are up to
the challenge i know you're just trying
to motivate me but these old ass eyes
will be reading your tombstone
son this is ridiculous neither of you
have even taken a bathroom break
are you kidding me do you think world
record holder howard berg would stop in
the middle of a read-off
to expel what's going on saudia it's
nothing
it's my guide finger got paper burn let
me see
santiago you're hurt don't be a hero
damn you must have been cooking i was
let's take a break put some ointment on
that
right and when i come back my finger's
slipping all over the page
nice try i'm not falling for any of your
tricks oh but you already have
while you were waggling your finger in
the air i've been reading all this time
out of the corner of my eye
damn it what's this meeting about did
someone find my meatball sub hey we
would never have a meeting about that b
you are holding it oh mini good journey
meeting's not over dummy terry said he
has some news from the office of
commissioner wunch ugh what does that
human blister want now does she intend
to demote me
even further or perhaps she'll transfer
me to the swamps of new jersey
so i can patrol the sinkhole where she
was spawned or it's possible the
announcement has nothing to do with you
oh good thank you peralta
you're right maybe madeline wants to
inform us all that she's a chooksy a
what
a chookson a korean toilet ghost lives
in an outhouse
wraps her hair around your throat and
chokes you to death while you move your
bowels you know what i will give you six
thousand dollars if the announcement is
she's a chookson
okay everyone i have some news the
madeleine munch is a korean toilet ghost
boring we already knew that madeleine
wuntch
is dead say what now wait wanch is dead
yeah the commissioner's office just
notified us no way that's true as once
says when she sees deodorant
i'm not buying it sir she's dead oh
terry
zombies can't die this is some sort of
scam if she were dead
we would be hearing the sounds of
children singing in the streets i don't
know sir
you didn't believe it when we told you
that disco strangler died either and i
was right he was faking it maybe she's
alive
why would once fake her own death the
same reason she visits mexico once a
year and sucks the blood from all the
goats
for kicks look i don't know what to tell
you but she's dead but what do you want
to open up her coffin and check for
yourself
oh she's very dead ding dong the wunch
is dead bagels for everyone
so i guess you believe it now yeah want
to see the selfies i took actually yes
i'll share the album with you
oh my god i just heard about lunch she
was so young
for a redwood tree uh i don't understand
what's going on why are you crying a
person is dead i
feel sad that's insane you don't feel
sad when a monster dies in a monster
movie
in e.t do you feel sad when e.t dies yes
he wasn't a monster he calls a real
commotion it isn't just lunch
i started seeing a fertility doctor and
she has me taking hormones to help with
ovulation and
my emotions aren't overdrive well i know
just the thing to cheer you up
watch is dead bagel bagel
bagel sir i am loving this color on you
but don't you think you should tone it
down why in case i run into her family
i'm not planning any trips to the bronx
zoo
wait does this mean you're gonna be
captain again it does the chief of
personnel called to say the promotion is
in the works her death means i've won
it's finally over
[Music]
an email from madeleine wanch subject
line
it's not over oh you must be feeling
better here heating up your favorite
meal
beans they're refried it's bad enough
they were cooked once let alone twice
and now the toaster oven makes it three
times
i couldn't be crying for help any louder
so i take it you couldn't get out of
organizing wench's memorial
oh no it's impossible she has bested me
yet again well then stop being such a
[ __ ] you idiot
amy sorry it's the hormones they're
making me really irritable
angry amy's right all you have to do is
say a few nice comments during the
memorial as god said when once tried to
sneak past the gates into heaven it
ain't happening honey
i tried to write a kind speech about her
last night and this is what came out
oh it's like 20 pages long why is it in
all caps
so i remember to yell it oh well you
obviously can't read any of this
look since you can't say anything nice
try saying the opposite of whatever
you're thinking
interesting i'll give it a whirl
madeline wunsch was
a friend see it's not that hard to say
something oh you're vomiting
[Music]
you